hi I'm Jill tarter and today we're gonna
do some et support we'll talk about life
beyond Earth first question comes from
at John Makuta if you found intelligent
life on another planet
would you tell the public the truth or
keep it a secret absolutely no way we
would keep this a secret John we are
going to tell the world it's just not
possible
to keep this kind of thing a secret and
we don't intend to at Korac says
extraterrestrial etiquette how should a
humanity interact with alien
intelligence I have to say that although
we're really proud of ourselves and we
think that we are the pinnacle of
evolution the top dog on this planet if
someone else can get from their star to
our planet they are in fact a lot more
technologically advanced I would say the
etiquette is we're gonna play by their
rules
antonio paris says why don't we assume
ET uses radio to communicate is setting
a waste of time and millions of dollars
what do you think well me I think
obviously not that's what I've spent my
career doing trying to answer this
really really old human question of are
we alone in the cosmos why do we use
radio well we use radio and optical
wavelengths particularly radio travels
across the very vast distances between
the stars in our galaxy without being
scattered or absorbed by the dust so at
least appease the fairy paradox
mathematically the universe should be
teeming with intelligent life so why
don't we see extraterrestrial versions
in all directions really interesting
question the answer is we've hardly
begun to look let me give you an example
if that volume of space we need to
explore is equal to the volume of all
the world's oceans in 50 plus years
we've observed only about one hot tubs
worth of the ocean maybe it's not so
surprising that we haven't detected
anything yet
we need to think
in terms of cosmic times and not human
lifetimes before we decide we're alone
because we haven't found anything at
Elie Maloney fit wants to know should
NATO and the US military developed
planetary defense systems in case of an
extraterrestrial threat oh come on get
real I think what we should develop a
defense system against asteroids
near-earth objects rocks that have our
name on it and that in fact could be big
enough that a collision with earth could
be civilization ending think about the
dinosaurs they didn't have a space
program if they had maybe they wouldn't
be extinct at Jodee Scott info is math a
universal language to make contact with
another intelligence or is this just
anthropocentrism probably if you're
going to be building any kind of
transmitter or receiver you need math so
in that sense it's universal but now
we're thinking the way that we express
math may be shaped by the very
configuration of our own human brains
math may be universal the function may
be universal but it may be that we will
have a difficult time understanding
someone else's expression of that math
you don't know love to have that problem
at Rachel eight four seven nine nine
nine seven four at what year do you
think we will discover aliens if ever
and Rachel I can't answer that question
all I can say is that if we don't search
we won't succeed it's an open question
and one that I think perhaps the 21st
century will give us an answer to at
vinyl on tour aliens will land on earth
you have only five songs to explain what
music means to mankind what songs would
you choose well I think the songs of my
youth are probably totally alien to to
you rather than songs I might go with
Bach because I think that is just the
most beautiful music we've ever created
Johnny be good that was on the Voyager
Golden Record as well as AZ box
so music is a personal taste I'd send
back and I'd brag at a car bunny we
assumed aliens look different from us
what if their intelligence is
unrecognizable how do you give them an
IQ test think about how are we going to
interact with them are we detecting
deliberate messages in optical or radio
wavelengths that they've sent us are
they here looking us in the face that's
going to determine how we interact with
them if they can get here they're a lot
smarter than we are
you can forget the test we'll just
follow their rules at Skip's ABS even if
there is other intelligent life in the
universe is our civilization even worth
contacting yeah
I suspect we are we're doing a lot of
things that are maybe not the wisest but
we are us we are different than they are
I think the most interesting thing in
the universe might be how diverse the
laws of physics and chemistry can make
life how many different ways can
evolution end up producing creatures
that are intelligent technological even
microbial how many different ways can
you make life that might be the biggest
question of the cosmos and one that
there'd be interested in finding out
what happened here at Bobby boliya wants
to know did US fighter pilots see a UFO
I don't know I've seen those videos too
I don't know what they are I don't know
whether the equipment which was in fact
quite new was behaving properly all I
can say is that there's no evidence that
indicates that that's spacecraft from
another intelligent species more than
likely we have some problems with our
own equipment it's going to take more
than that to prove that aliens are here
at will MC Kim how much do we think
this recent UFO news is prepping the
public for a discussion of actual
contact I think that like many things
our interest in this question is
cyclical we get really hyped up about it
somebody makes a claim people discuss it
and then after a while the Cardassians
do something else and we lose interest
what if we are the aliens that we seek
and earth was once populated by a much
more intelligent life force until we
destroyed it well think about that the
planet is really quite active about the
oldest rocks we can find are a little
bit more than four billion years old and
the planet we think formed about
four-and-a-half billion years ago now
these rocks produce the stones called
zircons and the zircon sometimes have
inclusions that have biological ratios
of light carbon to heavy carbon so we're
thinking maybe life went back that far
but we don't find any huge trash heaps
we don't find any evidence of foundries
or large structures or roads let's just
say we don't see any evidence for that
intelligence is proportional to the
number of thoughts we can simultaneously
call and hold in our minds as we explore
new ideas so what would we look like to
an alien species who could juggle ten or
twenty times as many thoughts as our
smartest human we wouldn't look very
intelligent would we we have to ask
questions not in our language but in
their language we have to try and
interact with non-human intelligence in
ways that they perceive and we're
beginning to do a little bit of that
with whales and with dolphins and with
an
of other species we can actually
understand that prairie dogs standing up
in the field are saying to one another
hey there's the big guy over there in
the yellow sweater he's back other
intelligence is going to have to speak
to us in our language if we're going to
have any ability to communicate at Gd
Bassett thought experiment
if Rai could lead to an existential
threat and there may be other
intelligent life in the universe what
about their AI yeah good question
I think it's quite likely that what we
will encounter is their artificial
intelligence it can be propagated in so
many different ways between the stars as
we build artificial intelligence and
hopefully as they built their artificial
intelligence they're going to be
constraints that build in to the
structure goals that remain consistent
with goals that we have for ourselves if
it's rogue game over what is the
organizing principle behind intelligent
life whoa what a question we can't
defined intelligence what we have done
to make progress in this field is to use
technology as our proxy for intelligence
so if we detect evidence of someone
else's technology out there we will
assume that at some time there was an
intelligent entity that created the
technology best we can do at Z Shaw if
there's a new planet cool own the real
estate will NASA get into the property
development business great question we
have confirmed over 4,000 other planets
around other stars the question of who
owns them who can mine them is you know
a work in progress the UN Treaty of the
outer space says that it is possible to
benefit from
an extra-terrestrial body without owning
it that no one owns it facing this metal
law if you wish on the law of the Seas
no one owns the ocean but people can in
fact salvage and fish and benefit from
the oceans that's kind of the playing
field that we're dealing now with
extrasolar bodies it's a work in
progress we'll see how it plays out at
code is broken oh yeah my code usually
is if aliens exist who could be far far
older than humanity and have used
similar coms tech to us how come we've
not heard a thing because the cosmos is
pretty damn big we're talking about
signals here for communication maybe we
need to look for something else maybe
we're doing an absolutely exquisite job
and looking for just the wrong thing
maybe we haven't figured out that the
thing that intelligent advanced
societies use to communicate is Zeta
rays and we haven't discovered them yet
at k-8 mommy Lisa what if they are
trying to communicate but we just don't
realize it yet yes absolutely
what if they're using some technology
some physics that we haven't yet
invented we could be missing a signal
the only strategy is to stay around long
enough so that we get smart enough that
we invent the technology and then we can
find the signal at captain fish bugs do
aliens have belly buttons yes well
that's a good question I'd love to know
the answer to that we look at various
forms of life on this planet not all of
them have belly buttons so it's possible
that aliens don't either
at et exists oh I like that when will we
hear from et and there are lots of hash
tags here I don't know the answer to
that question I don't know if et is out
there I think it's likely the universe
appears to be relatively bio friendly we
know about
lots of planets around other stars we
now know about lots of life-forms on
this planet that exist in extreme
extreme for us environments there's a
chance and the only way that we'll know
is to look and when I can't answer that
question talk to my great-granddaughter
she may have an answer for you
that was et support that's what I know
and mostly what I don't know but I'm
looking forward to learning more with
all of you